so many of my life choices
my wife choices
[Applause]
[Music]
and here we are thanks for that puff
kanye west references his estranged wife
kim kardashian in a surprise appearance
at the 2022 bet awards to present diddy
with the lifetime achievement award it
shocked the crowd yay stepping out in a
full face mask marking his first award
show appearance since he was banned from
this year's grammys
i took a little hiatus
i said i want to just like declare
myself legally dead for a year
nobody nobody messing me you know just
like i'm just want to be off the grid
and
you know puff is pretty persistent
but yay showed up for diddy who he calls
one of his biggest role models while
honoring puffy yay spoke on how the
anita girl rapper inspired him over the
years even poking fun at the fact that
both artists fell in love and had kids
with women named kim
i go to him for advice to this day
he inspires so many of my choices
so many of my life choices
my wife choices
[Applause]
[Music]
and here we are thanks for that puff
kanye is of course tied to kim
kardashian though they're going through
a divorce while diddy had a long time
relationship with the late kim porter
whom he shares son christian and twin
daughters jesse james and delilah with
on his big night diddy took a moment to
pay tribute to kim who died in 2018.
singing his hit i'll be missing you hey
baby girl kim this one is for you check
this out
come on
yeah it's kind of hard with you not
around know you in heaven smiling down
[Music]
e.t caught up with diddy's sons quincy
brown and christian king combs backstage
after the moving performance pop's been
waiting for this moment for such a long
time and for him to finally get his
flowers and to be up there on the big
stage doing what he got to do
i was just proud he went crazy though
it's an emblematic moment moment you
know cause like
we at the house with it you know so we
get to celebrate it at home but to
celebrate with everybody you know that
just meant a lot you know i was crying
up there just from being proud
and just like you know all the success
all in one i mean to just salute them at
the end of the day and before stealing
the show at culture's biggest night
diddy got praise from his industry
friends on the red carpet yes
he's so important to the culture and to
be et's culture
and we have to give him his flowers now
e.t also chatted with diddy's current
love young miami who was hyping up her
man before the show shout out to diddy
it's about him tonight in perry he
getting a lifetime achievement award
long time he was due right yes he was of
course
and if you blinked you might have missed
young miami giving her man his flowers
during his acceptance speech she was
spotted holding a sign in the crowd that
read go poppy as diddy accepted his
lifetime achievement award once again
thank you everybody without y'all i
wouldn't be on this stage
fans were quick to call out how diddy
left out young miami in his speech but
did surprisingly mention one of his exes
i got to give a special thank you to the
people that was really like there for me
and also cassie for holding me down in
the dark times love
young miami seem unfazed by the
situation responding to a twitter user
who called out the so-called shady
moment writing girl please
it might have been all about diddy but
it seems like he and kanye spent the
night giving most of the ladies in their
lives a little shout out
[Music]
you